Republicans make shocking gains in the
Senate Democrats win the house and
election 2020 begins today i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
I know you're all screaming oh no not
election 2020 can we have a moment to
breathe no no you can this is like when
the Christmas music starts in the middle
of Thanksgiving
okay 2020 has begun because it is now
after the 2018 elections I have a lot to
say about the 2020 elections I have a
theory of what Trump is electorally that
I think tracks much more closely with
the data than a lot of the theories that
have been out there before I came up
with it this morning and I'm very proud
of myself we'll see if you agree with
that theory just a little while first
let's talk about how you can make your
business more efficient well you can't
be using software from like 1996 if you
want your business to be efficient when
you are dealing with a real
head-scratcher around the house like a
plumbing or an electrical issue having a
go to person on call is a no-brainer
which is why I want to tell you about
software advice when it comes to picking
the right software for your business
software advice has done all the
research for you their team of advisers
can point you in the right direction so
you can start working more effectively
right away and it is absolutely free get
started at software advice right now by
answering a few short questions you'll
be connected with an advisor to discuss
the best software options for your needs
talking to an advisor takes just 10
minutes or less whether you're a medical
professional a construction manager and
HR pro you name it software advice saves
you time it helps you make a more
informed decision and the software
struggle today go to software advice.com
slash Ben to get started again that
software advice.com slash Ben to connect
with an advisor for free we are a
top-notch technology company except when
we move studios and don't have internet
access but one of the reasons for that
is because we have the best software
available you should too software
advice.com slash pen go check it out
right now software advice.com
slash Ben okay so last night was an
exciting night as the night started it
looked like Republicans were going to
defy all expectations of political
gravity by the time the night was over
it looked sort of like we had predicted
here on the show yesterday I suggested
on the show yesterday the Democrats win
35 seats turns out they won 34 it looks
like they're gonna win 34 in the house
and I predicted that Republicans we're
going to pick up anywhere from two to
four seats in the Senate which they did
it looks like they picked up three in
the Senate right now maybe four by the
time all of this is said and done now
this has led to a lot of puzzlement how
is it that Republicans could lose the
house but pick up seats in the Senate
well because the map was uniquely bad
for Democrats this time around in the
Senate but Republicans did overperform
and yeah
President Trump had something to do with
that president Trump visited a bunch of
battleground states in hotly contested
Senate races and every place he visited
a Kansan at one President Trump has a
unique gift for getting the base revved
up and particularly in close Senate
elections and that does matter so he
does have coattails when it comes to
getting the base out he does have
reverse coattails however when it comes
to House races virtually every purple
seat that was contested every seat in a
suburban district that Republicans held
went to Democrats last night that is
deeply troubling for Republicans so
there's good news for Democrats there's
good news for Republicans there's bad
news for Democrats and there is bad news
for Republicans the good news for
Republicans first the good news is that
the and beloved star-making candidacies
baito Aurora and Andrew Gilliam in
Florida they were roping in Senate
candidate in Texas those came to an end
last night all that came to a crashing
halt beta O'Rourke spent more money than
God has and still lost his race it was
shockingly close as a three point race
that he lost in Texas I think a lot of
that has to do with the deeply flawed
candidacy of Senator Ted Cruz who has
sort of mortally wounded himself in a
lot of ways since 2016 but with all of
that said Boehner O'Rourke did go down
in flames after spending one bajillion
dollars that is an actual number one
bajillion dollars was spent by Boehner
Orrick he went down anyway he's
basically like the Joker in Dark Knight
he just went around saying that it's not
the money that matters it's the point
it's the point just set giant piles of
money on fire so beta O'Rourke goes down
in Texas Andrew Gilliam goes down in
Florida he was another person who
according to polls was going to win Ron
de santis instead comes from behind and
snatches victory from the jaws of defeat
which is great I like governor De Santis
I know him he's a good man nice family
and all of the attempts to malign him as
a racist by a radical like Andrew
Gilliam went for not in Florida which is
which is great news so what it also
looked like Mike DeWine won in Ohio in
the Ohio gubernatorial race Republicans
kept a bunch of key gubernatorial seats
in places like Florida and Ohio where
redistricting matters also it is true
that they retained a bunch of Senate
seats that they needed to retain so it
looks like christen cinema
who is a radical radical leftist in
Arizona lost in martha mcsalley
which is terrific senator mcsalley
she'll be a great senator air force
pilot first Air Force pilot and combat
to be female and yet the media didn't
see see fit to cover that as a feminist
victory or Marsha Blackburn winning a
Senate seat in Tennessee that was not a
feminist victory the only feminist
victories were people endorsed by the
women's March of course but those who
are key seats obviously the Indiana seat
flips Joe Donnelly and Indiana Democrat
he loses to a Republican businessperson
so these are all big wins for
Republicans they do lose Dean Heller in
Nevada that was largely expected but
overall the talk of a blue wave was
overstated now how do you see this
election is dependent on whether you see
this as a year in which were pup in
which Democrats were going to ride back
in and overtake everything or whether
you saw this is a rebuilding year I
think the Democrats have a very skewed
view of politics thanks to the Obama
years I think that the Obama years made
Democrats believe they were never going
to lose again that Trump was an
electoral aberration and that therefore
they were going to sweep to victory
they're gonna come back in sweep through
the house sweep through the Senate take
everything back in one fell swoop
Trump was just a mistake it was just a
blip on the radar well it turns out
Trump is not a blip on the radar
Republicans are not a blip on the radar
the state seats that Republicans ones
are in Obama's tenure we're not a blip
on the radar if they had seen last night
as rebuilding the farm team if they had
seen it dana perino suggested this to me
this morning so I'm using her metaphor
if and I think she's right if Democrats
had seen this as we are in recovery here
then it was a very good night for
Democrats right they win back the house
they win
virtually every contested seat across
the country they asked a bunch of
Republican incumbents including
incumbents like Dave brat in Virginia
which is really not great I really like
Dave Brep congressman from Virginia who
else did Eric Cantor if you recall back
in 2010 all of this is to suggest that
Republicans have some problems now
Democrats have some problems because
Florida and Ohio are not solidly in the
Democratic line and that's problem for
them in future presidential elections
Republicans have a problem because some
states like Pennsylvania Michigan
Wisconsin those states look to be
trending back blue which is a real
problem for them if President Trump were
to win in 2020 Florida and Ohio but lose
Wisconsin Pennsylvania and Michigan he
loses the election right he needs to win
at least Wisconsin of those three
Wisconsin was very tight last night
Governor Scott Walker's bench from
Bendis governor was ousted an
extraordinarily close race that may end
up in a recount in Wisconsin but
political realities are back in play
so the polling was was flawed in 2016
the polling was a lot less flawed last
night that's why I was able to rely on
data and fairly predictably predict what
exactly was going to happen in the
overall numbers so there are a bunch of
lessons to be learned president Trump of
course is taking away the lesson that
he's awesome because he's president
Trump so he tweeted this out last night
and drew out tremendous success tonight
thank you - uh well from a certain
perspective that's true Republicans
gained a bunch of seats in the Senate so
many seats in the Senate in fact that it
will be very difficult for Democrats to
take the Senate in 2020 it also means
that president Trump's agenda for the
next couple of years is going to be
judges judges judges and more judges in
fact there's a case to be made that
president from gains by politically by
the Republicans losing the house because
now he just gets to punch Nancy Pelosi
he gets to do Rock'em Sock'em robots
with Nancy Pelosi for the next couple of
years Republicans basically had very
little legislative agenda anyway for the
next couple of years so now they just
get to blame the Democrats for nothing
happening and Trump gets to run against
Nancy Pelosi not bad for him however did
Trump have a massive down ballot effect
for Republicans that was negative yes he
had an appellate effect for people like
Ron de santis in Florida for folks like
Braun in Indiana
he had a ballot effect for for Ted Cruz
in Texas obviously but when it came to
the House races
the negative effect of President Trump
was pretty evident the exit polls showed
that am a huge number of suburban
districts did not like President Trump
do not like President Trump and that
there is blowback for president Trump on
that level so what we saw last night in
short red areas got redder blue areas
got bluer all of the trends that we saw
in 2016 were double down upon rural
areas went heavier for Republicans
suburban areas went bluer for Democrats
yeah is that a trade that Republicans
are willing to make maybe for now but
that's not a plan for the future with
that said with that said the Democrats I
think at least partially are looking at
this and saying well though there are a
lot of blown opportunities there no
close only counts in horseshoes and
hand-grenades and Andrew Gilliam nearly
winning in Florida is not Andrew Gilliam
winning in Florida and beta or work
nearly winning in Texas is not beta or
winning in Texas you can see Trevor Noah
was very disappointed last night on
Comedy Central
he said the Blue Wave was basically just
a smurf peeing so it was touch-and-go
for a while today the Blue Wave was
looking more like a swampy Smurf that
was peeing and what was worse is that
the results just wouldn't come in okay
so yeah I think that if you look this
morning as to who feels relieved and who
feels unsettled I think everyone should
be everyone on both sides should feel
both relieved and unsettled I mean
there's good again there's good news
from both parties and bad news for both
parties but I think the general
perception is that Republicans are
relieved and Democrats are unsettled
Democrats legitimately had expectations
that 2016 was a complete outlier and
that they were going to return to vast
power automatically just by dint of
people don't like Trump and that
obviously was not true now I think Van
Jones is take Dan Jones over the course
of the night you can see it was going up
and down like a yo-yo over on CNN but he
said that by the end of the night his
heart had been restored because
Democrats had retaken the house I don't
think this is completely unjustified
Democrats did take the house the the
wave did not break the levee but I don't
want to suggest that Democrats didn't
have a good level of success last night
again they won 34 seats in the house
that is not a historic upset you know
that's well within sort of the margins
of typical midterm elections but it is a
it is a win for Democrats there's no
other way to put it I don't know how
many hours ago it was you said this was
heartbreaking
where is your head now my heart has been
restored the end of one-party rule in
the United States thank God in the
beginning of a new Democratic Party
younger browner cooler more women more
veterans can win in Michigan can win in
Pennsylvania win in Ohio we have the
first Muslim women first Native American
women of the first black woman from
Massachusetts first Latina from Texas it
may not be a blue wave it's a rainbow
wave it's something happening out there
and I'm happy about it okay anybody who
believes that Van Jones has a good read
on this election is absolutely wrong
what actually happened is a bunch of
moderate Democrats in suburban districts
won and there were some Democrats in
more progressive districts who won in
more progressive seats but the notion
that a bunch of progressives swept into
power and that what Democrats have to do
in 2020 is double down more cowbell more
cowbell
rather there we
is more progressive and and if we run a
hardcore progressive in 2020 we're gonna
win that is not the lesson Democrats
ought to be learning I'm gonna talk
about the lessons both parties ought to
be learning in just a second after we
finished reviewing sort of what happened
in the election last night and why both
parties are gonna take away the wrong
lessons from what happened last night
but first let's talk about your sleep
quality now I know that when you think
about sleeping you think about a lot of
things you think about your pillow you
think about your mattress but one of the
things you probably don't think all that
much about is your sheets because you
just got a set of sheets for your
wedding or for your graduation or
something or you just went down to your
local Bed Bath & Beyond and picked up
whatever was on the Shelf there and it
had a high thread count you're like ooh
high thread count means that it's
awesome well the truth is you're she's
probably suck and what you really need
is bull and branch eats because they are
in fact terrific everything a bull and
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft they get
even softer over time you can buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand dollars in the
store but when bran sheets are only a
couple of hundred bucks even three u.s.
presidents sleep on bull and bran sheets
shipping is free can try them for 30
nights you really have nothing to lose
these sheets are so good that after I
slept on them I legitimately got rid of
all my other sheets and bought more bull
and branch sheets they are that
comfortable to get you started right now
my listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch calm
promo code Ben that's bull and branch
calm promo code ban again go and branch
calm promo code Ben for 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets that's bol and
branch calm promo code Ben okay so we we
should say a fond farewell to at least
some of the candidates who ran yesterday
beta or orc then a fond farewell to his
audience he will be back
obviously he ran a very competitive race
in a state where you should not have
been competitive he only lost by a
couple of hundred thousand votes maybe
three hundred thousand votes in Texas a
super red state and then he decided that
he's a cool guy so he skipped he flipped
boarded in he's skateboard in there flip
kick
stopped on the stage and then dropped
the f-word because he's cool they don't
work that's how you know that he's cool
he's like cool dog from The Simpsons
so here's Ben O'Rourke I want to thank
this amazing campaign of people not a
dime from a single pack all people all
the time
in every single part of Texas all of you
show in the country how you do this so
be proud of you guys
yeah I dropped the f-word he's super
cool but he said Wow they don't work and
I love the headlines from Reuters
whether he wins or loses Bader O'Rourke
is a big winner um well technically when
you lose it kind of a loser
I mean technically
I don't mean to get all you know
pedantic but when you lose that actually
counts as you losing so bitter work will
he be back yeah of course he'll be back
but kind of like John aw Soph there's
all this talk about like losing does
leave a stigma on you they all the talk
about beta overall for president 2020 I
think that that is pretty mature losing
does hurt you Andrew go up who was
supposed to be the rising star in
Florida he come from behind he'd won a
primary against a more moderate
competitor if he lost that primary
probably Florida has a Democratic
governor right now but Andrew Gilliam
loses to Ronda Santos which I'm very
grateful for works I think Andrew
Gilliam ran a terrible terrible race he
slandered Ronda Sansa's a racist for no
rational reason that I can put my finger
on at all he lost the race but he said
he's not going anywhere this is untrue
he may be going to jail actually
depending on the FBI investigation in
Tallahassee he is the mayor of
Tallahassee he's been ensnared in an FBI
corruption investigation in which he
took a bunch of goodies from an FBI
undercover agent here is the Andrew
Gilliam however saying he's not going
anywhere and then leaving but I can I
can I can't guarantee you this I'm not
going anywhere we're gonna fight we're
gonna keep fighting yeah he's going
somewhere like way um and again a lot of
these key races president from did play
a role in Chuck Todd pointed this out
and NBC News he is correct he says that
President Trump may have pulled de
santis across the finish line Brian Kemp
in Georgia who won a victory in the
Georgia race where he was not expected
to surpass these sort of runoff margin
he did so look from deserves a lot of
credit for a lot of these key races that
happened last night
president Trump weighed in on both
primers he got involved in both
primaries and pulled them both across
the finish line
and they're both gonna eat out against
proud progressive african-american
Democrats okay well that is that is
worth noting and I think that it is true
it is also true that President Trump has
up sides and president Trump has down
side so now let's go through some of the
bad news for Republicans because there
was a lot of good news for Republicans
last night so political points out and
they're right
suburban Republicans were swept away the
Republican Party in the house looks a
lot more Trumpy than it did yesterday
all the moderate Republicans are gone
now there are a lot of people who may
celebrate that oh we're a pure party
now you need those suburban Republicans
if you want to govern you do need people
able to win in the suburbs and the
demographic movements in the United
States are away from rural areas and
toward urban areas people are moving out
of these sort of outlying areas and more
towards suburbia more toward big cities
this is why that race in Texas was so
close because the entirety of the state
of Texas is deep red except for Austin
and Dallas in Houston and those are
exactly the areas that are growing so
for Republicans to sort of give up on
those areas and just you know wipe their
brow and say oh you know last night was
fine you know this is more like
Republicans should be worried about the
future of the party if the if the red
wave in 2016 begins to recede so
Politico points out Democrats won
suburbs from the eastern seaboard all
the way to Nevada
they didn't just pick off low-hanging
fruit GOP members long seemed to be
vulnerable expanded into Dallas Houston
Oklahoma City Richmond oh this is true
Republicans like Barbara Comstock in
Northern Virginia it's a good solid
congresswoman in Virginia she lost Mike
Coffman in suburban Denver Kevin Yoder
outside Kansas City Eric Paulsen in the
Twin Cities they all lost but they also
asked did Steve Russell in Oklahoma
which was a much deeper red and karen
handel in suburban Atlanta Democrats
when both toss-up races in Virginia they
knocked off both suburban Texas members
John Culberson in Houston Pete sessions
in Dallas incumbent Carlos kravello
crashed and burned in South Florida
Republicans kept only a handful of
suburban seats so obviously Republicans
have to worry about that you know when
one of the things that I'm seeing that's
hilarious today is Democrats saying well
you know we really did win in a way
because look at the popular vote in the
Senate this has really become a thing
stop being an idiot the popular vote in
the Senate doesn't mean anything one
third of the Senate was up the Senate is
not a popular vote body in other words
Montana has as many senators as
California racking up boats in
California does not help you in the
Senate not only that Democrats retained
there are 33 seats up yesterday hey
Democrats retained my 20 of those seats
so let's not get out over our skis when
we suggest that you public has rejected
Republicans and yet the system is
structured so the Republicans win anyway
no that's called the United States
Senate it's been there for quite a while
so stop being stupid the political
points out that Democrats may have lost
the Senate until 2022 as I pointed out
earlier the
remains that as of 2020 Republicans are
going to hold 54 Senate seats which is
three more seats than the GOP now holds
the 2018 map was bad the 2020 map is not
all that great if Democrats lose the
Alabama see which they will they only
won this time because Roy Moore was a
garbage candidate the only Republicans
up for reelection zin state hillary won
our cory gardner in colorado and susan
collins in maine susan collins is a very
good politician in her home state and so
there's a significant possibility the
republicans only lose maybe one seat you
know there there there they'd have to
have a wave basically in order for them
to take the senate in 2020 that seems
doubtful republicans did hold some big
governorships democrats hatched the blue
wall but it is still vulnerable so this
is a point that Politico is making it's
worth noting in michigan democrats won
the governor's race the incumbent
senator was reelected the party picked
up a House seat in Iowa Democrats picked
up two House seats in Wisconsin Scott
Walker went down and senator Tammy
Baldwin won re-election but remember
Trump was not on the ballot in any of
those places and as political points out
in 2010 Republicans won the
governorships in Pennsylvania Ohio
Wisconsin and Iowa and Senators in
Pennsylvania Ohio Wisconsin in Illinois
and then Obama won them all in 2012 so
Trump again was not really on the ballot
in any of those key states so maybe in
Wisconsin and Michigan and Ohio and
Pennsylvania Trump does better than the
Republicans did in this off year
election and one thing that the
Democrats are really picking up on is
that a lot of women won that's because
more women ran a lot of women ran and
they were in positions to wins that
makes a big difference but Democrats are
taking the wrong lessons from this
election cycle the lesson that they are
taking from this election cycle is look
at all the progressive radicals that we
got elected right because you Prai
married more moderate candidates in
progressive districts right Alexandra
Ocasio Cortese they think now is the
future of their party according to
people like Van Jones you want to lack
your own chances at national prominence
make Alexandra Ocasio Cortes the head of
your party you know tacked to that
extreme left what the American people
basically gave Democrats a referendum to
do was to check Trump in the house and
to act in more moderate fashion and what
they gave Republicans a referendum to do
was check the more ridiculous excesses
of the Democratic Party
but I don't think that's the message
that either party is gonna take away
from the election last night I'll
explain in just a second first let's
talk about that ugly thing that you've
got on your wrist you need a better
watch okay you just do a movement
watches are fantastic I have been an
advocate for movement for a long time
their start up team has made movement
the fastest scoring watch company in the
world and with their versatile line of
watches glasses and accessories you'll
be sure to find the perfect holiday gift
this season they've dropped their first
ever automatic watch the arc automatic
it is beautiful it looks fantastic
it's minimalist design it just looks
terrific they have their 1960s American
muscle car inspire a blacktop collection
I bring out new watches all the time
they all look great and they look like
luxury watches they are luxury watches
at a non luxury price movement watches
start and 95 bucks you're looking at 400
bucks from that same quality from a
traditional brand I promise you I
actually love shopping for watches and
so actually look to see what watches go
for online movement watches are just as
nice and nicer and a lot of more
expensive watches that you'd have to go
get at a department store there's a
reason a movement has sold almost 2
million watches in over 160 countries
movement has done all the hard work this
holiday season so you wouldn't have to
they made awesome gift boxes and
packages if you need help giving that
perfect gift this season but you don't
know where to start the guys over at
movement got your back they've curated
all your favorite styles and suspension
gift boxes just for you get 15% off
today free shipping free returns go-to
movement calm MVM tea calm / Schapiro
that's MVM tea calm / Schapiro again
check out their latest over there and
get 15% off today free shipping free
returns join the movement
MVM tea calm / Schapiro okay so what are
the lessons that they should that the
party should take away the lessons the
Republicans should take away is that if
they wish to see long-term success
they're going to have to start appealing
to these suburban districts in other
words the districts that Mitt Romney did
better in the Donald Trump are still
important if Donald Trump can hold the
rural districts in the way that he has
and he has because Democrats have
polarized if he can hold those and
somehow start appealing to those
suburban districts Democrats are in
trouble by the same token if Democrats
keep appealing to suburban districts
with moderate candidates and the
Republicans are in trouble unfortunately
it seems that everybody is doubling down
on what brung them there and what that
means is the Democrats are
embracing the radicalism and Republicans
are embracing the excesses so
everybody's gonna take the wrong lessons
from today like the Democrats you saw
that clip of Van Jones a little bit
earlier heard the clip of Van Jones a
little bit earlier talking about how he
is so excited that all of these
progressives have been elected well that
there were a bunch of progressives
elected again mainly in areas in which
they supplanted other more moderate
Democrats this is something the
Washington Post is pointing out moderate
Democrats in the Midwest outperformed
ideological Democrats in the Sun Belt
this is an absolute fact and that's an
important thing to recognize okay that
if the Democrats had run a bunch of
moderates they would have done better
across the country than they actually
did instead they are championing the
fact that people like Rashidah Rashidah
Slade and ohan Omar won their
congressional seats they're the first
Muslim women elected to Congress that's
fine the only problem is they are deeply
deeply radical it slave didn't have any
Republican challengers in her district
so once she won the primary issues in
Congress and ohan Omar was the favorite
to prevail in a solidly Democratic
district both of them are radically
anti-semitic and anti-israel the
Democratic Party is celebrating all of
that the Democratic Party is out there
championing the fact that Charisse
David's a lesbian Native American
becomes one of the first to Native
American women elected to Congress and
the other one is not Elizabeth Warren
she's the first openly LGBTQ kanzen okay
but the fact is that the candidates who
won last night overwhelmingly our people
who are not talking along radical lines
they are overwhelmingly in the
Democratic Party people who seem sane
and not crazy
and yet the Democratic Party could take
away from this what we need is a base
that is jazzed up the intersectional
coalition rides again
the intersectional coalition is not a
thing the intersectional coalition does
not actually win victories they they
here here's actually something that
Democrats need to recognize look at the
Texas race for just a second what you
see in the Texas race a lot of people on
the Left very very upset about beta or
beta or or losing to Ted Cruz in Texas
and they look at the voter breakdown
what they see is that 95 percent of
black women voted for beta O'Rourke and
71 percent of white women voted for Ted
Cruz
and you're seeing tweets like these
white women are tools of the patriarchy
first of all keep saying stuff like
that's definitely gonna win you
elections is insulting the base that you
need to win that's definitely gonna help
you out second of all what that actually
suggests but that actually suggests is
that you believe that you are going to
make more hay by somehow winning 98% of
the black vote and alienating the entire
white female base like Democrats
actually have less upside in a lot of
these minority communities than
Republicans have upside in those
minority communities what I mean by that
Democrats if they blew it out but only
won a hundred percent of black female
vote in Texas Republicans if they blew
it out could win another 29 percent of
the white female vote in Texas and
there's 95 percent of the black female
vote they could theoretically go after
there's not a lot of room to maneuver
for Democrats they may have maxed out
their intersectional coalition and the
numbers just aren't big enough that
means the folks they need to be
appealing to are those white women not
insulting those white women and yet what
you see is the Democrats are in fact
insulting those white women they're
insulting people who are not members of
the intersectional coalition it could
take the wrong lessons from all of this
the states Democrats need to win again
in the 2020 election if they wish to
oust President Trump they need to win
Michigan and you do win Wisconsin and
he's win Pennsylvania if they win those
three they win the election the entire
election is gonna come down to those
three states those are states where the
intersectional coalition is not going to
be enough those are states where you
need to be able to appeal to a base and
the Democrats in some ways are getting
more and more radical as I say a couple
of anti-semitic Democrats won last night
keith ellison became Minnesota Attorney
General despite all of the controversy
dogging him the fact that an
ex-girlfriend accuses him of beating her
up so I guess that he beats someone else
last night who is not his ex-girlfriend
Bob Menendez in New Jersey who may end
up in jail for allegedly preying on
underage women in the Dominican Republic
he ended up winning his race in a walk
and just showing you what New Jersey is
man I mean New Jersey just astonishing
New Jersey a juror in Menendez his trial
showed up at his victory celebration I
am not kidding here's video of her
[Music]
yes that's that's that's that's really
great she served on and then as his jury
and then when to his victory party the
Democrats have double down on that on
the other side the Republicans are
doubling down on the Trump and when I
say the Trump I don't mean they're
doubling down on President Trump I mean
they're doubling down on the effect now
imagine for a second that Republicans
had not doubled down on Trump's effect
that in the last three weeks of the
election they run on Cavanaugh here's
the the weird thing about sort of how
the the late-breaking news narrative
played into this election cycle so Brett
Kavanaugh hurt the Democrats there is no
question every Democrat who voted
against Brett Kavanaugh in a red state
loss last night pretty much all of them
I think maybe one exception Claire
McCaskill went down Heidi Heitkamp went
down they're a bunch of areas where
Democrats lost and lost big because of
Brett Kavanaugh hey Joe Manchin did not
lose partially because he did not vote
against Brett Kavanaugh if that had been
and that was because Democrats exposed
themselves as partisan hacks of an
extraordinarily ridiculous and an
extreme measure that would have cut in
Republicans favor Republicans in kind of
hotly contested districts lost last
night part of that is because the
closing pitch for the Trump campaign was
doubling down on the base now do you
think that Ron De Santis won in Florida
because of the talk about the migrant
caravan I don't I don't think that he
won Florida because of that I think that
it had very little to do it that do you
think that that martha mcsalley won in
Arizona because of the migrant caravan
talk I really doubt it I really doubt it
because three weeks earlier she was
skunking Christian cinema and then it
really tightened up in the last three
weeks so the Republicans who believe
that President Trump appealing to the
base is the best strategy for electoral
victory that's sort of missing the point
what people want from President Trump if
Trump if the best version of Trump were
available it would be the president
Trump who is capable of fighting back
against the radical left and punching
and punching but doing so in a
manner that is strategic as opposed to
sort of it driven and if the Democrats
had any brains they would be running
blue-collar candidates with moderate
appeal it seems however that both
parties are determined to double down on
what the base wants not what the rest of
the voting public wants and that spells
a very contentious couple of years or
we're gonna talk in just a second about
what the next couple of years spell and
then I want to lay out a theory for you
about President Trump 2020 Barack Obama
that I think few people have actually
discussed as of yet first let's talk
about for a second how much you are
spending at the post office so I know
the post office is great there lot of
great services but do you really want to
spend the time in the cards you really
want to be spending the time and money
on gas to get in the car drive over to
the post office for your business why
not just have a service that allows you
to do all the great things the post
office does right from your desk and
then you just click print mail you're
done right mean this well that's what
stamps comm is for stamps comm allows
you to access all of those great
services 24/7 whenever it's convenient
for you you can buy in print official US
postage for any letter any package using
your own computer and printer big mail
carrier picks it up you click print mail
you are done use stamps calm here at the
Daily wire our offices it saves us time
and it saves us money right now use
promo code Shapiro for this special
offer fifty five bucks of free postage a
digital scale and a four week trial
again net scams calm before you do
anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in promo code Shapiro that
stamps comm promo code Shapiro and when
you use that promo code Shapiro you get
that special offer up to fifty five
bucks and free postage a digital scale
and a four week trial
it really is terrific it saves you time
and it saves you money there's a reason
we use it here at the Daily wire stamps
comm use that promo code Shapiro okay so
I want to talk about what an alternative
history of the last month in politics
would have looked like electoral II and
I also want to talk about what's coming
next and my grand theory of from 2020
but for first we're gonna have to go to
subscribe over at daily wire calm right
now $9.99 a month means that you get the
rest of this show live means get the
rest of claim initial live you get the
rest of Knowles's show live we had tons
of people who are watching our daily
wire backstage if you wanted to ask us a
question you had to be a subscriber in
order to do that plus when you subscribe
you also get access to the final
question on our Sunday special this week
Sunday special features features john
stossel who you'll remember from fox
news
libertarian reporter
really has some interesting thoughts on
the economy and the future of the
country here's a little bit of what that
sounds like hi I'm John Stossel annoying
libertarian I'm gonna be in the ben
shapiro show his sunday special this
sunday talking about individual freedom
and not invading lots of other countries
okay so that is an interesting
conversation gonna want to go check that
out this sunday please subscribe over to
itunes or youtube and leave us a review
at itunes it really does help our
rankings over there we really appreciate
all your support please subscribe
tonight by the way ninety-nine dollars a
year get to the annual subscription it
is cheaper than the monthly subscription
and so you and you also get this the
leftist year's hot or cold tumbler the
only thing that sustained me through
last night's marathon session in in
covering the election you too can be
sustained and emboldened by the leftist
here's hot or cold tumbler go check it
out right now they're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so President Trump has
responded to the the Democrats winning
the house we'll get to that in just a
minute
but I do want to discuss what the
alternative timeline looks like for the
election last night if it had not been
about immigration if President Trump not
swivels have been in Cavanaugh all the
way down I think Republicans have a
better shot in retaining the house and I
think they win the same number of seats
if the Democrats had not done Kavanagh I
think Democrats do much much better in
the Senate and I think that they have a
better shot of winning the house so
basically both sides did their damnedest
to blow this election and neither side
was completely able to all of which
speaks to 2020 which is what I know
what's on everybody's mind I mean let's
take a look at the 2016 map real fast so
if you look at the 2016 map in in you
know in the presidential election what
you will see in this map is that
President Trump won at 306 electoral
votes it that means it takes 271 if
President Trump were to lose Michigan
Wisconsin and Pennsylvania that is 46
electoral votes
it means he's down into 60 he loses the
election if he wins Wisconsin but loses
Michigan in Pennsylvania he's got 270 if
he loses one of the votes in Maine he
won one vote in Maine if he loses that
one vote in Maine which is probably
likely at this point then he can win
Wisconsin and you end up with a to 69 to
69 tie right which is just everybody's
worst nightmare a win a tie in the
electoral college which gets thrown into
the house where Nancy Pelosi presides
which is just nightmare scenario but the
reason that I'm bringing up this map is
because the theory of President Trump's
the president from finally broke that
blue wall that existed in Pennsylvania
Michigan and Wisconsin and that the
Democrats thought that that was an
outlying effect here's my theory my
theory is that President Trump is
basically a reversion to the statistical
mean that there is not as giant from
movement wave surge that has changed the
nature of the country anything like that
and what actually happened is that
Barack Obama was an outline candidate he
was a statistical outlier and that what
is happening in states like Ohio and
Florida and Wisconsin and Michigan and
Pennsylvania is much more of a reversion
to the Bharathi pre Barack Obama era and
it is anything else
which says to the
Democrats that you're intersectional
strategy is a giant fail it says to
Republicans that they need to do better
in reaching out to suburban areas but it
really is a rebuke to the intersectional
politics of Barack Obama so here's my
evidence for the proposition that what
has basically happened here is a
reversion back to the pre Obama era
let's take a look at Ohio in Ohio the
lists recent presidential elections
George W Bush versus Oh 2000 Republicans
when 50% of the vote
2004 Republicans win 51% of the vote
then Obama comes along and Obama breaks
the mold right he wins Ohio with humans
Ohio and Republican boat share drops to
47% and 48 percent respectively
then President Trump comes along
Alabama's no longer on the ballot
Hillary's uniquely bad candidate and
Republicans win 51 percent of the vote
again I said what that means that that
is a reversion back to the pre Obama era
that is not a difference in kind it is a
it is a reversion back to before Obama
see the Democrats think that Obama
changed the world Obama didn't change
the world Obama was just a uniquely good
candidate and Trump for Republicans
didn't change the world
Trump was running against a uniquely bad
candidate and he was a reversion to the
statistical mean here is my evidence
with regard to Florida
hey in Florida Republicans won 49
percent of the vote in 2050 2 percent of
the vote in 2004 then they won in 2008
and 2012 48 and 49 percent of the vote
in 2016 Trump won 49 percent of the vote
he won the election because Hillary
Clinton lost the election he actually
won a lower percentage of the vote in
2016 then Devin then Republicans won in
2012 but he won because Hillary Clinton
was a crappy candidate again reversion
to the mean in Florida Wisconsin what
about this this shocking victory in
Wisconsin where no Republican had won
since 1984
look at the vote shares for a second
2000 Republican vote share 48% 2004 49%
then Obama comes along again statistical
outlier that vote chair drops to 42% and
46% then by 2016 it is back up to 47
point two percent again that is lower
than the percentage of votes won by
george w bush in 2000 and 2004 that is
the reversion to the statistical mean
Michigan same thing
a Michigan 2000
Republicans win 46% of the vote 2004
47.8% of the vote and Obama comes along
41 and 45 percent of the vote then 2016
48% of the vote forty-seven point five
so again Trump wins a lower share of the
vote in 2016 than george w bush won in
2004 he wins the state that's a
reversion to the statistical mean it is
the same thing in Pennsylvania where the
Republican vote share was 46 49 in the
Bush years and it dropped radically
during Obama and then it was back up to
49 drink trump what this suggests is
that the country is still actually
broken down very similarly to the Bush
era
it's just that Barack Obama broke the
mold but that mold could not be broken
for anyone else that mold did not apply
to anyone else so the Democrats are
still doubling down on intersectional
politics Republicans all I have to do is
play the bush-era cards and they still
have a shot at winning in all of these
places but just as Bush lost a lot of
those battleground states Wisconsin
Michigan Pennsylvania right just just as
Bush lost some of those states the
reality is that pariah is that Donald
Trump is gonna have to do better than
Donald Trump did in 2016 if he wants to
win again in 2020 and that means
channeling his anger it means less a
less surrender of the suburban boat
that's what this means if you want to
win that's what it is so let's not
deceive ourselves on the Republican side
of the aisle by thinking okay we're just
gonna win from now until the end of time
because these races last night and let's
not pretend that it was trump that saved
Florida or Ohio Barack Obama was not on
the ballot Hillary Clinton was on the
ballot and Donald Trump yes he's great
at a certain number of things but that
is not that luck is not a business
strategy as I've once said my business
partner and it is not a political
strategy either
okay so what comes next what comes next
year could actually be good news for a
president Trump Nancy Pelosi is running
the house that gives him a nice big
target to hit and Nancy Pelosi is is
smarter that I'm giving her credit for
in the past she's attempting a sort of
moderation because I think that Nancy
Pelosi does get that not everybody can
campaign as Nancy Pelosi and went across
the country here is Nancy Pelosi last
night talking about what the election
was really about what she says here is
actually accurate it's about restoring
the Constitution's checks and balances
to the Trump administration okay so when
it when it when she says about checks
and balance if the Democrats restricted
themselves to checking Trump's worst
impulses they'd be in good shape the
question is can Nancy Pelosi ahem in her
own base I don't know that she can I
don't know that she can't an example of
this last yesterday before she gave the
speech she was asked about impeachment
and she said no I'm not interested in
engagement but her base is very
interested in impeachment they want to
conduct investigations of the president
they even want to impeach the president
that serves their purpose to say that we
certainly will honor our responsibility
as oversight of the executive branch
will there be a move to impeach the
president it depends on what happens in
them and in the Moller investigation but
that is you not unifying and I get
criticized in my own party for not being
more and supported that but I'm not if
that happens it would have to be
bipartisan and the evidence would have
to be so conclusive right so that is
Nancy Pelosi understanding that if she a
lien AIT's the moderates across the
country it's a mistake I wonder if the
Republicans are gonna learn the same
lesson president Trump gave a press
conference today in which he discussed
the election and his entire election
strategy was everyone who didn't like me
lost everyone who liked me won that is
not true everybody who liked President
Trump in Trumpy districts won everybody
who liked President Trump in purple
districts lost a president Trump is
gonna have to understand and if he wants
to win reelection it's not gonna be
enough to just double down on the gal
that brung him he's gonna actually have
to he's gonna actually have to change
strategy a little bit it looks like
Nancy Pelosi actually understands that
which is scary I want her not to
understand that I want her to lose right
I don't want to answer Pelosi in charge
of government I don't want a
Elizabeth Warren as president of the
United States I would be remiss if I did
not point out that Nancy Pelosi also is
a gaffe machine last night she she
actually called for people to cheer for
pre-existing medical conditions like yay
diabetes
yay mesothelioma here is Nancy Pelosi
McConnell was thus also a Medicare
Medicaid the Affordable Care Act and the
health care of 130 million Americans
living with pre-existing medical
conditions let's hear it more for
pre-existing medical conditions ten
people cheer like yeah pretty and even
the kids who are next are like why am I
even here man just get me out of here
just get me out of here now
again well Nancy Pelosi be able to
continue to contain the enthusiasm of
her own base I I have serious doubts
about that the base is clamoring for
investigations which is going to be not
terrible for Trump more investigations
look Trump it's all baked into the cake
man if they get his tax returns and it
turns out that dude gives charity -
puppy slaughtering mills no one's gonna
care legitimately everything is baked
into the cake for Trump if Democrats
want to waste their time for the next
couple of years in investigations they
can do that the only thing that I think
damaged Trump at all is if they came up
with some evidence of emoluments that he
was self enriching or something but even
there I don't think that there's gonna
be much Adam Schiff however who has now
he's now gonna be the head of the House
Intelligence Committee and he is
suffice to say the Adam Schiff has moved
his pup tent from CNN's greenroom over
to the House Intelligence Committee he
says there will be more investigations
more cowbell more cowbell I think that
the chances that Bob Muller will be able
to finish his work
improved for the reason that our
committee and others like the government
reform committee and the Judiciary
Committee which under Republican
leadership served as basically
surrogates for the president in their
efforts to batter down the Justice
Department to give the President to
pretext to fire people the Justice
Department all of that that that tearing
down of the independence of these
institutions is going to end okay so
this is you know their pitch I don't
think that that pitch is going to play
in 2020 I
being a natural pessimist means I think
that every party takes the wrong lessons
from last night's elections but again
they're encouraging signs and
discouraging signs for both sides in
that election if people are willing to
read the tea leaves there's a lot of
upside for Republicans if they don't
there's gonna be a lot of downside okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things I like
you know it is true that we are an
amazing country in which we get to
transfer power safely from one party to
the other in a variety of chambers
checks and balances keep our rights safe
for the most part and yeah that is a
wonderful thing and puts you in kind of
a patriotic mood Aaron Copland but you'd
recognize a lot of his music because
he's responsible for Appalachian Spring
I he's he did a version of rodeo which
is which is fantastic we'll have to play
that it's kind of cowboy music but here
is his fanfare for the common man you'll
recognize this as well and there is
something uniquely American about this
this sound here's Aaron Copland's
fanfare for the common man
[Music]
it's good stuff today give a listen to
it if you're in the mood today and why
not be in the mood today this is a
pretty spectacular country no matter how
elections go on a one-off basis and
we're voting transfers of power like
this totally normal when people say that
that oh the Republicans didn't hold the
house there has never been since in in
the last century or so since 1968 since
1968 no party has held all the house
dissent in the presidency for more than
four years since 1968 so last night was
fairly predictable and it also provides
some good data and I have to say I root
for data I like data because it gives me
something to go on it allows me to
actually make my analysis smarter I'm
sort of happy that the data was
justified last night even if they got
the the race is wrong in places like
Florida ok time for a quick thing that I
hate ok so this is pretty amazing Lisa
Milliband
over at Marie Claire has the stupid
column of the day it's called Y Trump's
America makes me regret adopting my
daughters it makes me regret her
adopting her daughters cuz she's a crazy
person here's what she wrote our
daughters came home from China more than
a decade ago the first time their tiny
feet touched American soil we made a big
deal of it we were so happy about
everything they did inherit as newly
minted Americans are already head over
heels in love for them every opportunity
we could afford and freedom from China's
oppressive government and its
controversial one-child policy the same
policy that was most likely the very
reason they were available to join our
family half a world away but now I worry
we made a tragic mistake you're right
leaving kids in a chinese orphanage is
way better than bringing them to the
freest country in the history of the
world and most prosperous country in the
history of the world probably you should
have left them in the chinese orphanage
you crazy person and she says i pulled
these two beautiful babies away from a
rising power and into a damaged
democracy really that's AC china in the
united states the united states is
damage to democracy and China is a
rising power China is a fascist
one-party state in which people do what
the government says up to and including
their their actual number of children I
brought two girls of color into a
society where it's clear that their word
in their bodies are worth less than a
man's hey you won't talk about sexism in
China yeah it's an actual
thing it's an actual problem is it the
reason that why do you think to a bunch
of girls we're available for adoption in
China not a bunch of boys because of
sexism in China and if you think that
racism is uniquely American phenomenon
it is not OK for example black panther
in the United States opens to enormous
numbers enormous numbers right like
world-shaking numbers black hands are
barely did business in China
racism is actually a thing around the
world this is where open over racism has
become even more likely than it was a
decade ago according to this woman and
unfortunately my worries aren't exactly
tinfoil hat wearing paranoia well no
actually they they they are there two
years ago rights this crazy person
I brought my daughters to the voting
booth with me expecting they witnessed
the election of very first woman
president instead we got a guy with
multiple sexual allegations made against
him who backs candidates for the highest
post in the land who also have assault
and molestation claims against them
again keith ellison is the new Minnesota
Attorney General guys and Bob Menendez
is the returning senator from New Jersey
me too may have brought the conversation
about sexual assault out into the open
and helps clear the entertainment
industry as some of the worst offenders
but the current administration seems far
more willing to promote and prosecute he
accused um no actually that's not
accurate
right there are those of us who one of
the great ironies how many times did you
hear any Democrats say you can't vote
for keith ellison did i hear one of them
I didn't hear one of them anyone say no
one should vote for Bob Menendez I
didn't hear one of them how many
candidates have I said Republicans
should not vote for because it would be
a moral blot a bunch including Roy Moore
don't give me this crap about how
Republicans don't police their own we
police our own hell of a lot better than
Democrats to even in areas where we fail
at least there's a kickback at least
there's a kickback like there are a lot
of Republicans were upset that Steve
King retained his seat in Iowa last
night how many Democrats were upset that
keith ellison won the attorney general
seat in minnesota and keith olson is
hell of a lot more racist than then
Steve King even says from promised
during his campaign who would roll back
row v Wade and a new Supreme Court
justice Brett Kavanaugh is conservative
judicial record makes it seem he'd be
just the man's help to it no matter his
prata stations that he considers it
settled wha the idea that my daughter's
may lose the right to control what
happens to their bodies especially if
they could end up with a pregnancy
that's the result of a sexual assault
keeps me up at night well it's kind of
weird that your self
abortion considering that your
daughter's literally are alive because
they avoided forced abortion at the
hands of the Chinese state is that as
well again the the reason that I read
this from Marie Claire is not just
because I'm picking on a crazy person
but because unfortunately this base of
the Democratic Party is fully convinced
that the way to win is by shouting and
screaming like a crazy person
so it's it's really really a really
mistake really really stupid so well
done everyone just calm down calm down
everything's okay all right well we will
be back here tomorrow with all the
latest breakdowns plus president Trump
reacting in extraordinary fashion to the
election we'll have all of it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing